This one goes out to all of y'all who's struggling to get high views on YouTube
I'm about to tell you the secret that no one knows about except me
Cause I just figured it out Listen carefully, boys and girls
Ayo, it's the never one falcon lover back Now sit down, relax, hear her have a snack
Have a mountain to six pack I'm sorry if my grammar's wack
But we're getting off the track The song is about Iraq
No, I'm not talking about the nation I'm gonna tell you all about the great titillation
If you're first at videos for more interviews And some nice music news that might come to you
We've all been there, we all have struggled We tried to pay for subs, they just said no to scrubs
We tried to do collabs, they just gave you some crowds
You tried to false flags, you didn't mess up false flags
Was the secret to you two views? There must be a trick
Are they part of the monotony? No, I swear they can't be it
Do they work really hard? Do they commit?
You've got it all wrong, the secret lies in the tip
Blue's in the thumbnail, bitch
Give some money out of winning, fucking quick
You know I can't do that, that's not really nice
Run your mom, then you gotta think about it twice
Blue's in the thumbnail, bitch
Okay, okay, sorry, sorry
The trick is simple, I learned from the best
The secret lies within my messy, fully blessed chest
You may want to consider having implants You may want to consider having implants
Now don't get me wrong, I'm not being sexist
As long as you have boobs, it don't matter what your sex is
But don't use a picture of your dick Ain't nobody gonna click on that shit
Come on, man, ill, that's gross, ill
You should consider having implants You should consider having implants
Everybody, you should consider having implants You should consider having implants
Another time is to commit Are you gonna be a bitch?
Are you gonna make people click on that jiggly dick?
Just think of other views, I know you want it, just get it
And better than making the twelve years, get busy with it
Blue's in the thumbnail, bitch
Guess I'm money out of money fuckin' quick
Guess I'm blue's in the thumbnail, bitch
What about my integrity?
Just kidding, as long as I can put a bouncy boob in
You should consider having implants
Everybody, you should consider having implants
But, uh, I'm a boy, I don't want an ambulance
Will it let you go?
You should've said I had an ambulance
Ups, ups, ups
You